[Musique]
mais pourquoi elle a toutefois s'être
cesse ses petites filles à une maladie
[Musique]
la cause de cette maladie
eh bien elle était invitée partout
dans les cours d'europe parce que on est
à la renaissance donc à la renaissance
et au 16e siècle époque où étaient
construites le château ont trouvé que
c'était quelque chose d'extraordinaire
on savait pas si c'était une petite
fille comme toi oui si c'était un animal
du coup bon lanfrey on la donnait
la faisait circuler de cour en cour à
l'époque on pensait que c'était
quelqu'un qui était pas tout à fait un
humain
[Musique]
c'est bizarre qu elle a vraiment existé
c'est pas quelqu'un d'inventer un la
vraiment été pâtes dont elle était
patent c'est la date voilà raconte son
histoire
c'est une histoire vraie c'est une
petite fille prévenu alain père qui
était poilus mais sa maman était pas
poilu l'histoire de son père et de sa
mère a été racontée par un poète italien
à l'époque est à partir de cette
histoire
eh bien il ya une dame au xviiie siècle
en france qui en a tiré un compte
il se compte c'est la belle et la bête
mais en fait c'est l'histoire de son
père et de sa mère et de leurs enfants
[Musique]